every few hundred years we get a work of
art that completely redefines its medium
beethoven's fifth the mona lisa die hard
masterpieces individually but together
interwoven threads in the endless
tapestry of history
equal parts depicting and dissecting our
civilizations
inspiring countless generations to
tirelessly participate in the eternal
collaborative effort to articulate the
human experience
every culture is judged on the art it
produces and each piece of art a product
of its culture and on october 6 2016
the most important art form of all anime
finally received its culture defining
masterpiece
as the world was graced with the gift of
[Music]
keijo
is a difficult piece of art to analyze
as most of you know my preferred medium
for consuming these types of stories is
manga
not anime so naturally i use my fiance's
credit card to order the entire series
in paperback from overseas however
roughly halfway through the third volume
it came to my attention that the entire
story was actually written in japanese
and although i was shocked to discover
how easily i could follow the
titillating plot through the assets of
his visual storytelling alone
to truly immerse myself in the rich
thick lore of the keijo universe i felt
it was necessary to understand the
expertly written dialogue
as best i could and as such i made the
difficult decision to switch to the
anime instead
and that is exactly what we will be
discussing here today and let me tell
you
there is more than a handful to discuss
right here with its flawless pacing
seamlessly covering two condom two
tournaments and a training arc in 12
tight episodes kjo has not only proven
itself the pinnacle of anime but also
renders all anime that came before it
redundant
and so i had decided to remove all of my
previous videos and retire from youtube
as soon as this analysis goes live as i
fear that the act of even discussing
anything else serves only to distract
from the bigger
picture but i'm getting ahead of myself
to truly convey the subtle genius of
keijo then we have to start
at the beginning our story opens with
our hero nozomi experiencing her first
professional cage battle from the
bleachers
kjo is a sport in which women stand on a
platform surrounded by water and attempt
to knock each other into the pool using
only their breasts and buttocks
a masterful twist on the old boring form
of combat typical to lesser shown in
anime often reducing themselves to using
tired tropes such as punches and
swords both of which have been around
since at least world war ii by rejecting
the obvious means of battle and
embracing the new keijo opens up a whole
new world of possibilities and
immediately breathes new life into the
dying genre of action
it's worth noting that while any
rational person could immediately
identify the artistry of ass slinging at
a glance
it seems as though nozomi is primarily
motivated by the huge cash prizes
awarded to winners of kjo tournaments
implying she comes from a less than
privileged background having abandoned
her previous profession of gymnastics in
hopes of pursuing something with higher
potential earnings this immediately
endears us to nozumi as an audience
casting her as the underdog in an
unfamiliar world following her heart and
taking risks to provide for her family
as an audience we have been introduced
to and fallen in love with
both a well-developed new character and
an entirely new sophisticated high
concept sport all within the first
five minutes of episode 1. this is truly
masterful storytelling and
interestingly in an intricate display of
non-linear narrative
we flashback six months to the kjoe
school's entrance exam where we are
exposed to the enormous skill sets of
the other students and despite an
impressive display of her talents in an
unprecedented turn of events
our hero actually loses her final battle
after receiving a devastating ass to the
job
to say i was in legitimate awe of this
twist of fate would be a gross
understatement
as someone who has been following anime
and manga as far back as i can remember
i can't recall a single instance of a
shonen hero being defeated most notably
goku who has never lost a fight since
the beginning of dragon ball over five
years ago
and although the loss does ignite a real
passion for the sport within nozomi her
low score in the entrance exam
places her in the infamous room 309
reserved for the worst keijo athletes
but it's here we are properly introduced
to the rest of the main
cast kazani aoba a cute socially awkward
girl
nontoyoguchi a cute socially awkward
girl who also has a soft butt and sayaka
miata a cute socially awkward girl who
gave up a promising judo career so that
she could wear
cute swimsuits it's perhaps the most
diverse cast of rich characters with
relatable motivations
i've ever seen in modern literature and
over the next few months the girls
engage in rigorous training including
moving their butts and also
moving their butts again ultimately
resulting in a deep bonding experience
and the discovery of hidden talents
aoba comes out of her shell and is
revealed to have a hand so
sensitive it can detect changes in the
wind a skill she utilizes by giving the
best
possible ass massages to each of her
fellow students
miyata realizes her prior judo
experience has granted her increased
speed but struggles to fully utilize
this ability
none continues to have a soft butt and
ozomi discovers her ability to use an
incredibly powerful
but equally dangerous technique the
vacuum butt cannon in which
the user must thrust their hips with
such speed and force
it creates a sonic boom-esque explosion
so powerful it can obliterate the very
clothing of its targets
ladies and gentlemen i ask you to take a
moment to commit this image to memory
each curve of a supple breast
the helpless expression of their
delicate faces this may be
the single most important frame in
animation history
and its haunting implications when fully
assessed are sure to shatter the very
fabric of its beholder's psyche
yes this dear viewer is the genesis of
cajo's dark
and sinister undercurrents
three months into her first year our
heroic band of misfits are finally given
the opportunity to show what they've
learned during their class exchange
tournament
in which the lower class students do
battle with the elite class
and even potentially take their place
should an elite student be defeated
however the students who rank lowest in
the tournament will lose
their position in the school setting the
table for a perfect high stakes
high reward showdown we hold our breath
for our eight larger-than-life
protagonists as they prepare for the
biggest firmest challenge of their
collective careers
first up we have the former judo expert
miata versus rin
an elite student and the self-proclaimed
fastest butt in western japan the battle
quickly turns into a test of speed with
both combatants seemingly equal in their
ass-slamming pace
however we learn that rin is renowned
for her superhuman lung capacity giving
her an
edge stamina-wise and in the final
moments with all hopes seemingly lost
miata resorts to an experimental
technique hoisting her swimsuit high
above her hips
granting her greater mobility catching
her opponent off guard and
ultimately claiming victory this is a
brilliant example of subverting
well-known anime tropes where often
characters acquired their power by
eating forbidden fruit being an alien or
generally by being some flavor of chosen
one however in kaijo
all the special moves are human
abilities that exist in the real world
making this show possibly the most
realistic down to earth anime i've
ever in my life seen then there's
nontoyoguchi who wins her battle by
having a soft butt
and next up is aoba vs mio a match-up
that seems honestly hopeless for poor
aoba particularly in the face of mio's
enormous skill set her herself having
never lost a single cajole battle in her
life
but the fight itself gets off to a
shocking start as oba tenaciously begins
commanding her teammates with
unquestionable authority and flawless
insight the girl who could hardly bring
herself to speak in episode 1 has fully
developed into a strong
confident young woman neil is shocked at
not only ioba's leadership but the
accuracy in which she can read her
movements
at which point it's revealed that aoba
can actually read a person's disposition
condition and even their habits much
like the wind
using her incredibly sensitive right
hand and all she has to do
was touch her targets but the massages
that's why ioba offered the massages to
all the other students it wasn't comic
relief or fan service
it was an ingenious ploy to gather
invaluable intel
of her future opponents i can honestly
not describe the emotion i was feeling
while watching this
i had never seen such holistic
storytelling a narrative technique
wherein the writer subtly introduces
concepts and events
seemingly menial at the time but which
will hold massive significance further
into the story this is a literary device
so new and bold that scholars have not
yet agreed upon
a word to best describe it and perhaps
it's not meant to be articulated
only felt and feel this i most
definitely did i'm not ashamed to say
that this honestly reduced me to tears
anyways then mio hypnotizes everyone
with her giant titties and knocks them
all into
the water
[Music]
and that's when it happens we finally
have nozomi
kaminashi vs kotone fujisaki a purebred
athlete from a long family history of
keijo
serving as a perfect inverse to the
outsider nozomi
fujisaki begins the fight like a booty
possessed lunging ass first at her prey
dispatching her opponents without even
looking at them it's revealed that she
has no love for the spore of keijo and
instead allows her cheeks to fight on
their own using her prestigious family
ability to summon the guardian of hades
itself
cerberus and in this battle the war of
opposing ideals is about to begin
one born into a life of riches forced to
join keijo by family obligation and the
other
choosing to join the sport to escape
poverty but slowly discovering a true
passion a battle hinging on the gifted
cerberus versus the hard earned
vacuum butt cannon fujisaki with
greatness thrust upon her
and nozomi thrusting her greatness upon
others
but in the face of insurmountable bods
and climactic clashing of cheeks
nozomi manages to knock her opponent out
of the ring winning the day and proving
to us
all that hard squats beats talent when
talent
hardly squats and although the victory
may seem bittersweet with fan favorite
and national icon kazani ioba having
lost her placement match it is revealed
that neil's titty hypnosis is
actually a forbidden technique resulting
in her disqualification from the match
and securing all four of her heroes a
place
in the elite class a group of underdogs
once assigned to the humiliating halls
of room 309
through dedication hard work and
absolutely redonkulous booties have
proven themselves a force to be reckoned
with a tale
as old as time finally perfected having
now ascended to the top of the class the
girls are subject to even
tougher training regiments such as
walking in a river and
ripping turnips out of the ground using
only their asses all to prepare them for
the annual tournament against the rival
upperclass school from across the
country
the famous east versus west war where
keijo's true
eldritch nightmares are finally revealed
to us
in full display but before we talk about
that we have to talk about the profound
subtle horror that is lemon stealing
[__]
lemon stealing horrors is an infamous
pornographic film starring james dean
haley page and
joanna angel as the titular lemon
stealing [__]
and it is possibly the single most
frightening piece of media
ever produced the scene opens with a
young couple waxing lyrically about the
beauty and value of their beloved lemon
tree they discuss the possibilities
their lemon tree affords them and
even compare their love for each other
to that for their love of their tree
however conflict enters the fray as our
antagonist the lemon stealing [__]
appears and begins stealing their lemons
whorishly the cup will ultimately catch
the perpetrator confront her and
i guess then they have sex i'm not sure
i've never actually made it that far but
on the surface this might seem like an
offbeat if not otherwise remarkable
porno but
look what happens if we take a moment to
consider the horrific implications of
the world these characters inhabit
when we remove the sex scene i wish i
was a legend
you wish you were lemon if you were a
lemon i would put you on my shelf and
cherish you like i cherish all our
lemons
that's so beautiful i try who are the
lemon-stealing [__]
are they a race a class a creed how do
the couple know of their existence prior
to this encounter
what is it that draws a [__] to a lemon
like a moth to the flame
why have an entire band of horrors
dedicated themselves to the theft of
lemons what has happened in the society
that not only the lemon stealing [__]
but the orders of the lemon trees
themselves all inherently recognize the
impossibly high value of the humble
lemon and what does it say about that
society that some can only theoretically
infinites a plant lemons while others
are left to scavenge and steal and
presumably starve or at least get scurvy
questions that are handwritten by the
promise of a sexual encounter are now
devoid of rationality if you remove
the climax and this is the nightmarish
hellscape kjo's cast are forced to live
in
every day with everyone outright
refusing to accept the inherent
sexuality of their actions
during the final battle we see our
heroes obliterate their underwear
perform judo using only their nipples
and make direct
face to butthole contact in front of a
stadium full of spectators including
their parents
and no one seems to recognize the
implication of their actions
no one in this universe knows what sex
is
even more troubling the characters will
sometimes react in such situations but
only very briefly and under extremely
specific
circumstances the first instance of
nozomi using her vacuum butt cannon and
disintegrating the other girl's
swimsuits
renders her teammates completely naked
and understandably
embarrassed however in the very next
scene those same girls are just as naked
in front of just as many people to no
reaction
even more interestingly some of the
characters claim to be sexually
interested in boys or girls throughout
this series but consistently failed to
recognize the meaning of that claim like
children playing house as a husband and
wife
completely oblivious to the implications
so i ask
what is causing everyone to behave like
this perpetually on the cusp of sexual
realization but doomed to slip into the
all-consuming
ignorance that is keijo and by the way
why in a world like
this is keijo of all sports the most
popular
and why does the opening of each episode
feature a non-corporeal all-knowing
entity very deliberately avoiding the
word sport instead
choosing to describe keijo as a new form
of legalized gambling
what does keijo even mean directly
translated from japanese it says
seoul the capital of south korea is the
south korean government involved in some
sort of mass brainwashing conspiracy to
exterminate the content of sex from
japan thus eradicating an entire
country's population within a single
generation
why when i explained this to my fiance
did she leave to stay with her mother
but not before recommending i go see a
therapist
is she in on it too i mean yes it's an
anime about tna
if t and a stood for terror and
abhorrence
of course the girls win the [__]
east west war
but who [__] cares about that we need
to investigate the true nature of cajo
millions of lives are at stake what does
the author daichi story omi know
hey look don't hurt me let me go
open your eyes people free yourselves
from the event
keijo is a wholesome juggernaut of
literary prowess that offers the perfect
evening for the whole family to enjoy
stream it now on crunchyroll.com or you
can buy the manga in japanese like i did
special thanks to tom o'regan for making
this video script as hilarious as it is
if you want more of his deep analysis
click the left most video on screen now
or follow the link in the description
also april fool's
jokes aside cajo is a surprisingly well
animated and charmingly written show you
should definitely check it out and no my
editor isn't making me say this
end video don't say this out loud